oh my god this uh is to
cut the music cut the music okay that's
too intense or
is it because it's not this is storm
works
kick the music up that's not as dramatic
as i thought it was gonna be right then
in there replace the music with
something even more intense dramatic and
life-threatening
i am in charge of your life
scary right i'm gonna rescue you
from certain death terrifying am i right
and i'm gonna do it with a craft that i
built with my own
hands not scary because i've got good
hands and you're in good hands
when you trust me i don't know how this
is gonna go because it is
exactly what i said you build your own
rescue vehicle and then you actually try
to go rescue people and
that seems horrifically irresponsible
given that they must know that people
like me would be
holding on to this having this in our
hands
that's not me look at that gap my god
look at the thighs look you could you
could palm that whole grundle
two hands ugh anyway okay random
randomized what oh ah oh randomize
what randomize that's not bad i'm not
too opposed to that that's
that's pretty good there's something
going on here hey wait a minute hold on
a second
[Music]
there's something happening here
you know what that's fine i love this
traffic light color combo but it's just
slightly off this should be yellow and
this should be green
now that's perfect yep that's me all
right okay i'm done
so if if if building a vehicle is just
as easy as building a
human i think we're gonna have a good
time hello
why would i pick this up why would i do
that
why would i pick any of this up why do i
push it so far away from myself walk to
the hill
yeah you got it all right
what am i looking at when it well
ow i will not walk to the stairs i jump
down the mountain
i didn't know that that was an option
gotta go to the top of the stairs so the
tutorial knows that i actually
wasn't an idiot walk to the dock you
walk by walk you mean sprint at full
speed
because that's what i'm doing interact
with the boat helm
helm
on starting
throttle oh
oh that's inconvenient okay navigate to
the source of the distress call there
was a distress call
according to who did who did that give
up
you don't want me there dude stop uh
engine temp is
hot why it's
cool stop i don't know cool down is this
something that i actually have to worry
about
how far away am i going to save these
people i really gotta get back home
i got video games i need to play i gotta
play some hades
man you know all my time is dedicated to
pretty much doing only that
if this is some [ __ ] straight oh fire
fire
if it's just some [ __ ] stranded by
fire i'm gonna be very upset
oh it's just some [ __ ] stranded by
fire
use the extinguisher stored in the floor
of my boat
my boat's floor is made of fire
extinguish what are you
what remain calm do not
pan i am stuck on the beach reverse
throttle up max reverse oh i probably
should have used the dock i'll be right
there
okay there we go
oh god no reverse reverse oh now i'm
stuck again
it's 20 32 apparently we can't get a
boat that can go backwards
oh oh my god i'm sorry
i didn't mean to criticize your boats i
didn't mean it
man i there's a truck that's easier to
drive than this
boat oh stop what are you doing
stop it you crazy maniac drop anchor
oh what is this boat i'm gonna kill this
boat i'm gonna destroy the
i'll get to your fire in a second i
gotta kill a boat i have to
i have to kill a boat
[Music]
i have to kill it i will loop around
i'll come back and
i'm gonna loop i'm gonna go for a
loop-de-loop god
wish i could see the throttle literally
anywhere but looking down at it
my god it's at 50 and i'm going this
this is 50. what is this 50
is this 50 this is 50.
it's so the throttle's on a logarithmic
scale is that what you're telling me
and drop anchor
literally stop i'm done with you god
okay
fire eerie here oh drive
drop here okay i'm coming home coming
this is definitely not an indication of
my future services to save people
i'll definitely be a bit more
expeditious the next time that i come to
rescue you
hey where's the fire in your loins
where's the fire in your loins
all right here we go yeah that's the
good stuff yep this is working
apparently yeah this is definitely
working um
did it done heal the survivor using your
med kit on the boat you could told me to
get that
i'll be back for you just keep standing
even if you're injured
got a bad leg put all your weight on it
don't put any pressure on your wounds
that'll infect them
[Music]
oh there we go okay first aid kit i'm
coming don't you worry
hope is all the way very slow this hill
is immense
i can't possibly navigate up this hill
oh how come
i'm shut down all right i don't know
what i did but it helped you're welcome
i'm gonna pick you up
where are you where are where is
them let's see them out of the corner of
my eye come with me
yes come with me please we're gonna go
we gotta get out of here you there all
right good buddy
jump missed it back that much
you're right there pal hope you're still
on my back i don't know
all right come on buddy jump
jump can i just pick him up could i just
pick him up here
you yeah okay that's great can i pick
you up
can i just pick you up can i pick you
guys
can i ah oh there's a ladder on the
other side i'm just gonna go are you
kidding me i have to go all the way
around that i can't
oh my god what is th how do people swim
is this is not swimming by the way
just want to put that out in the
universe oh my god manifest this [ __ ]
i'll pick you up come here you [ __ ]
we're going home god no
here you go okay
great okay we are getting out of here
hospital rescue the survivor to the
hospital
i can't read that how would i read this
why is that designed like that what
this game is clearly not broken right
this game is clearly put together
but how am i breaking everything
is it me is it me game is it me give me
a sign
game is it me over he's dead you're just
glaring at me i healed you you guys
couldn't have walked
look i don't want to be ungrateful but
you guys really couldn't have walked
where's the anchor rope anchor bro i saw
it i saw it rope anchor anchor rope
broke rope egg i saw it i saw it it's
okay thunk that's gonna have to do okay
that's gonna have to do
we're gonna throttle down and uh it's
kind of a
head-in-only parking okay uh you come
you first
you're probably the most injured maybe i
don't know and we're getting out of here
baby to the hospital you could have
walked but whatever
man i'm slow when i got this [ __ ] i'm
it nope
i'm fast cause i i jump with 160 pounds
on my back better than i run
oh this this game should not have given
me the bunny hops okay
hey hey doc uh
[Music]
what
injury number two
doctor are you sure are you sure
doc what
are you i haven't even built my device
to rescue people
uh that was the main draw where are you
going are you st
are you stealing my boat uh are you
stealing my are you stealing my boat
you stealing my boat listen you get on
my back
because we need to go there's an
emergency
somewhere that's more urgent than you so
if
i can't climb ladder with man on back
yes i can
just not always here we go now can
do bra
you got time that jumps perfectly uh oh
i'm nailing nope
nope yup yup there we go yep
uh you don't want to be any further
you know i get it you don't want me
carrying you literally any
longer than i legally have to i
appreciate that that's good
and you're stuck outside now [ __ ] i'm
pulling out my way
to success
[Music]
get back here what are you doing what
are you doing
you're running away from me paintable
sign did i see paintable sign what does
that even mean
okay starting throttle all the way
let's go let's go god let's go look
navigate back to beginner outpost
oh i'm sorry i didn't know i was on
scrub island you could call it the
heroes outpost because that's what i am
and that would be much better but you
decide to insult me
so i will take vengeance whenever
possible
and we're home
i probably should have backed it into
here because backing it out manually is
gonna take forever and if there's an
emergency then
clearly that ain't gonna happen oh what
is with this
what is this okay now we're not
bobbing like crazy i don't know why that
was a thing
keep an eye on your fuel and top up from
fuel pumps okay that's a good
idea fluid on valve
lart paintable sign what pump's on
no hose inventory full how
what get rid of it how do i drop how do
i drop a night
how do i drop an item i don't i don't
know man i don't know is that parked
that how is that not
sunk fluid valve hose i am into
whatever look man i don't know man i
don't know
uh edit vehicles oh here we go
there it is the promised land
how do i respawn my vehicle you said
something about respawning the vehicle
respawn respond but it costs money this
costs
a lot of money spawn i did it there she
is
looking like a beaut i did it i'm going
to bed
that was a fine day's work i'm happy
about that
i'm going to bed wake me when i leave
hell
which i'm in i have to press another
button to sleep
and to wake up apparently god if i could
just do this oh stranded vehicle has
been reporting the ocean when do i get
to the good
[ __ ] come on give me a good [ __ ] there's
i know there's like planes and stuff in
this
i know there's like planes right
can i get to those i thought i saw
planes is that not a thing in this game
looks like there could be planes
helicopter oh i did it again
hey look at that no it's not a plane
that's a tractor that ain't no plane
can i build a plane oh boy you should
not let me do this
work work work shot i have no money
go back main menu
quit the menu okay new game
career classic career starter here we go
here we go screw the ocean the ocean
ain't what it about i'm going the
harrison
air base add-ons i don't know whatever
cool let's go all right okay good
no i don't do i want anything to do with
the ocean
probably not oh oh wow
oh wow oh wow
wow oh wow okay oh hey
wow look at you all right looks like
someone's about to make a sweet ass
airplane okay how do i do that
okay good this would have taken so long
to build so i'm glad that that's not
what we're [ __ ]
god that's having a gun has
okay spawn great
i earned this um anyone in need of a
rescue
engine starter extinguish fire and
rescue two casualties that saw your
islands to a hospital
okay engine starter and engine starter
apparently the
what what
and oh they're electrical
what is this a beat up old helicopter
what what's
oh it's already started okay uh
auto hover what how do i go
up am i am i
up am i office don't worry guys i'm
coming
help is on the way am i anchored to the
ground or something
is there like an anchor for this
what what happened am i dead how did
why how did i die how did i die who
killed me
wait how many what did i get chopped up
into [ __ ]
okay what is actually happening
deprecate deprecated
what do you mean deprecated
what do you mean deprecated how
how i'm dead again i think
that means my head gets cut off every
time i try to leave that thing
how many times must i live with this
hell
i can tilt it forward but it no go
am i too heavy that's not right
what is that doing
[Music]
turn it off let me out and don't kill me
this time
i'm dead i am really
having a time with this guys we're going
to euro fighter
spawn that bad boy in i need to rescue
these people they
uh you're in my way don't matter here we
go
how do i ladder la ladder okay
ladder all right nope not ladder
ladder ladder ladder ladder
in the pilots the hot ass i saw that
said hot ass okay canopy canopy okay
uh afterburner we don't need that quite
yet
okay starter okay
throttle oh
landing gear oh that was necessary
here we go i guess you better oh
you better get out of my oh no
helicopter don't do this to me
oh helicopter don't do this hey what's
happening god i hate
i hate i hate so much i hate i've never
hated
get me out of your ejector seat where's
the eject button
i can't un-throw there's no unthrottling
now kill me kill me
kill me please kill me no oh my god
oh my god oh my god kill me kill me kill
me
kill me kill me everybody kill me ah the
return to work [ __ ]
hot ass ladder come on hot ass okay
can it be down start if you throttle up
hit it baby there we go here we go
okay turn not
my god mountain mountain
everything's fine everything is under
control
i've got this just gonna respawn that
euro fighter i'm gonna go get this
ladder
staircase stairs lad stairs stair ladder
how nope not all right gonna get in the
plane throttle only up to
53. so i see the fire up there but
that's okay
all right we're gonna go forward we're
gonna go forward
we're gonna go forward
there we go okay bring that down bring
it to bring it down it's too toasty too
toasty
we're gonna turn
nope how do we turn turn turning turning
how's that done
how does one turn turn turning
is turn how do you turning
[Music]
how about i look at the controls right
okay sad music is kind of fitting but uh
let's pump up the cheer a little bit
let's get some cheer in here cause uh
now i i'm gonna really get it really
gonna get it i'm
really getting it okay canopy chunk
starter rattling up what the deal is
there's the left and right arrow keys
which is what's really important
yeah oh my god okay left and right arrow
keys
are what's actually important
okay runway little lit oh my god
oh my why why why oh my god why
holy [ __ ] oh my why
what are you doing
what okay we we did it
i don't understand you i don't
understand you at all
but we're going for this nothing can
stop us i'm up i'm up
i'm up i'm up i did it i'm up
oh my god that's so sensitive the
tiniest tap
turns me so much okay let's turn off the
afterburner okay afterburner is off
okay we're uh oh
my god
we're stalling we're stalling we're so
we're not selling we're not selling
we're gonna
save it
i'm going back in the helicopter now
that i know that maybe up
up arrow okay of course it's up arrow
okay where am i i'm not touching
anything
auto hover
why are you so jiggly
and there you go instantly down oh
cool that was storm works
i fully blame myself for every horrible
thing that happened to me and everyone
who needed to be rescued in that
endeavor
but also
so if you want to play this game it's
linked in the description i don't know
what multiplayer is
like but if anything in my experiences
to go on it's chaos
utter complete anarchy and maybe that's
good
hey probably good i hope i'm the one
that needs to be rescued
because i can just die in peace so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down in the
comments below i will not play this
again
no matter what you say so don't ask not
because the game's bad probably not
because i'm clearly not cut out for it
thank you
take care as always see you next one
[Music]
bye-bye
oh